juste gabriela talent ce soir les
téléspectateurs
ils ont compris qu'ils avaient une
urgence moi j'ai entendu dire qu'on
avait maintenant une dizaine de jours
pour vraiment effectuer les bons gestes
et peut-être sauvé 1re confinement est
ce que c'est vrai cette affaire est-ce
qu'on est sur le bon chemin
ou est-ce qu'on est sur un chemin qui va
nous mener un confinement il ya beaucoup
de gens qui parlent d'un long
confinement pour les vacances de la
toussaint ccd question que tout le monde
se pose
je suis sûr que ces questions vont être
posées vous vous posez c'est la question
que vous les posez également je suis sur
vos autour de la table est-ce qu'on peut
répondre clairement à cette question
aujourd'hui ou pas ce qu'on peut dire
d'abord c'est qu'il ya une situation qui
est préoccupante en france qui est
préoccupante dans le monde entier
puisque le virus a repris dans beaucoup
de pays dans le monde mais qui est
préoccupante en france parce qu'il
circule circule beaucoup chez des
personnes âgées et parce qu'on voit une
augmentation des cas graves qui arrivent
à l'hôpital en réanimation et des décès
aussi mais ce qu'on peut dire aussi
moi je pense que c'est toujours
important d'avoir de l'espoir sinon
seraient pas là en train d'en parler
c'est qu'on peut encore prendre le virus
de vitesse parce que le virus
aujourd'hui ils circulent trois fois
moins vite qu'ils circulaient au
printemps dernier dans la première vague
en printemps dernier une personne qui a
attrapé le col vide en moyenne elles
contaminé trois personnes aujourd'hui en
moyenne
elle contamine un peu plus d'une
personne parce que les françaises sont
mobilisés parce qu'ils ont été
responsables parce que tout le monde
porte le masque au travail a le masque à
l'école masse dans la rue parce qu'on
fait attention aux distances et parce
que voilà il ya cette responsabilité
chez les français et finalement il faut
peut-être encore un peu plus d'efforts
notamment dans certains endroits pour
arriver à faire reculer ce virus et ce
qui est certain c'est que si là il n'y a
pas cette mobilisation dans les peut
être deux semaines qui viennent
d'accord ça sera peut-être difficile
d'inverser la tendance et moi j'ai pas
envie que cette émission dans quelques
semaines ou dans quelques mois on sera
obligé de la faire depuis notre canapé
chacun sur zoom nous ce qu'on aimerait
c'est que ce soit en fasse avancer les
choses et qu'on va se passer les bons
messages et se soit pas du bullshit j'ai
envie de dire c'est à dire que les
français se mobilisent et qu'après on se
disent ouais c'est trop tard ça a été
pas ce soir je pense que tous ici ils
valent des vraies réponses et de vraies
solutions c'est-à-dire pour savoir
est-ce qu'on peut sauver 1 re
confinement pas qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire c'est vrai que vous vouliez ce
soir gabriel
voilà et des jeunes parce qu'aujourd'hui
ce sont les jeunes qui portent qui pose
le plus problème parce que ils sentent
et je les comprends
moi je vois gg voilà vous avez tous des
potes voilà qui ont peut-être qu'ils ont
peut-être été touché par la cobi 19 et
vous dit ouais bon bah ça va il est
resté un jour à la maison et puis ils
allaient bien réponse est pas rendu
compte mais c'est eux qui posent
problème parce que derrière ils sont en
fait ils respectent pas les gestes
barrière est ce qui fait que le virus
continue à progresser
d'abord parce que je veux dire c'est que
les jeunes ça a été des héros du
confinement et de ski c'est vrai c'est
au printemps dernier on a vu des jeunes
dans les hôpitaux ce soit des internes
des jeunes médecins
on a vu des jeunes qui travaillent dans
les supermarchés qui sont aller bosser
la boule au ventre parce que ils avaient
peur et qu'on savait encore pas grand
chose de cette épidémie on a vu des
jeunes qui étaient confinés chez eux
mais qui ont aidé des personnes âgées
qui habitent dans leur immeuble en
allant faire leurs courses et moi je
pense que les jeunes ils ont la
possibilité d'être les héros de ce
moment là celui on va empêcher la
deuxième vague comme celle qu'on a vécue
au printemps de survenir et c'est vrai
que pour ça il faut une mobilisation
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le virus il
circule le plus et il a le plus circulé
ces dernières semaines chez les jeunes
parce que il ya eu l'été parce que
peut-être qu'il ya eu un peu de
relâchement et en même temps moi je je
je n'aurais jamais j'aurais jamais
donnerait jamais de leçon de morale
cette épidémie ce virus il est nouveau
on le découvre tous il ya quelques mois
les jeunes et tous les français il
entendait les scientifiques les membres
du gouvernement alors expliqué qu' il
fallait pas porter de masque aujourd'hui
le masque qu'il est devenu obligatoire
la recherche avance les choses elle
changé donc je n'aurai pas de jugement
de morale je dirais pas que ça circule à
cause de ce que je dis c'est que s'ils
se mobilisent et ben on peut terrasser
le virus